米ちゃん外れ殺王ですあの僕はテスト期間なんであずで釣っても勉強しないといけない
んですけども
生意気な後輩ユーチューバーがありますねちっとという音がいるんですよ動画見なくて
いいですよそいつがねぇ今日猫ちゃんね本当に山ではまず生意気なんですよ見て分かる
通りこれ急ぎのでこの態度ですよこの俺様に向かってこの俺様に向かってですよ外れ朝
静岡言いますか
いる塗るくらいからいきますからテストレンギョだってという話をして分かります
頑張ってくださいと来るわけじゃないですかそれからの映画以降
舐めてるでしょっから今日になっていきなりまず電話ですからね何コレ高校前なんだよ
で原電はゼロと何事とびっくりしたんですチェスト臨月入ってたからテスト勉強し
なきゃと実は新年の挨拶をしに行きました
教え
でも前から言ってたんで今日はムリっと言う渡部がそれでな感じでその時は無理と言っ
てたからそういう話を捨てて何かこんな写真が僕にちょっと近くまでも来てるんですよ
こいですよ
なんかドッキリしようと思ったと言ってごめんなさいってという流れでございますどう
もいますか言いそうするしかないよな
テスト期間がこの餌までにと水規制後半 your tears バーンッ
の強さを押して頂ければと思います ok 山ちょっと持ち待っててはーいで早速
仕掛けの準備していきましょうパンサーこちら
はいあー大量のビー玉にちょっと追加します以上の大量のビー玉の中にこちら配慮の
スーパーボールを受けます
すごいなこれは階段からが持ってくださいって書いたから乗っているところを目が決定
これをぶっかけてやると思います
みーたままのっちく作りたいんです b でマチックすぐに対しスバル跳ねる
ブレーカーの恐怖とが元気の今日っていう離断供給がを組み合わせで攻撃牛包んで
だいぶ強いと思います気が気が気が怪我しない程度の怪我しない程度のスピードで
ぶつけてだろうと思いますでは
エコ配とりあえず今から来るんですけども階段この改善からあいつでくるのでここから
今年であると思いますねちょっと落とすときように撮っ
できたさこういう感じでここはさあ
と言ってよさといって欲しいと思います ok
やっておりましたどうせ
ok
持っています
me
ああああああ
ます
気持ちいい
長生きだろうへ出かけたい方い
なぜこんなことをされたかが分かるか
サブチャンネルでもプロとがあるもの
俺は言ったぞ line で言ったとちゃんとセットチャネルの紹介だ
いやもうどんなちゃねーかいい場面の登録してくるべきました
そんな先人脚はここで登録さ増えればシグナル